I learned this back doing door-to-door sales, okay?
So for example, back doing door-to-door sales,
we were always taught that you do business,
people do business at the kitchen table, okay?
And that was, your chances of closing a deal
at the kitchen table were far better
than sitting at the couch with Jack, the retired Marine,
sitting at the couch while he's watching TV,
way better at the kitchen table because he's focused,
he's watching you, he's paying attention,
and we're doing business, okay?
So the equivalent of that, and this is the first thing
that I would say is a best practice,
I want you guys to write down,
is get them on a desktop or a laptop,
none of this phone bullshit, okay?
Here's why, if they're on their phone,
that gives them the ability to be in their truck,
that gives them the ability to be at the store,
that gives them the ability, who was I on the phone with?
I did a close with somebody, or maybe it was just me,
I can't remember who it was.
Oh, guys, she's not in this group, Preeti,
if you guys watch, I was on her close
when she closed the deal a couple months ago,
like three, four months ago, right?
And we didn't do this, well, she set the whole thing up,
I just hopped on, the guy was on his phone driving,
and he was buying dog food, like, we still got the deal,
we still got the deal, but he was buying dog food,
I was so pissed off, I'm like, bro,
we are literally talking right here,
and you're buying dog food, so make sure they're at a desktop,
make sure they're at a laptop, and if you do that,
they're not gonna be able to be driving around,
or doing this, or doing that,
or jotting down notes, or whatever,
make sure they're at a desktop.
Now, how do you do that without making it sound weird?
This is what I would recommend, I would say, hey,
if possible, please be at a laptop or a desktop,
because I wanna show you a couple things,
it's going to be really hard for you
to see on your tiny little screen.
That's how you're gonna do it, okay?
So the equivalent of sitting at the kitchen table,
in door-to-door sales, which me and Lincoln are familiar with,
and I know Marcus has done door-to-door sales as well,
is being at a desktop, being at a laptop, not on the phone.
Not on something that they can move around with, okay?
Something they gotta sit their ass down and pay attention.
What that's going to allow you to do,
it's going to allow you to get their attention,
and they're gonna move everything else,
and they're just gonna be focusing on you, okay?
It's gonna be really hard for them to get up,
and go get a drink,
because they're gonna have to carry their damn computer,
and if they're at a desktop, they can't, okay?
So make sure they're at a desktop, if at all possible,
and do it by saying, hey, I wanna show you a thing or two.
If you can be on a desktop or a laptop,
that's gonna make it way easier so you can see the screen.
It's gonna be really hard to see on your phone,
which is true, by the way.